there was a viral video
right there was a vowel video and there
was a lady named by the name of ali okay
it's pearl's friend it's my friend as a
matter of fact i was in miami this week
yeah
yeah with my friend ali yeah i was in
miami
yep i know ally i was in um miami with
ali and i asked ali about her marriage
she showed her ring
and i asked her as pearl right
how did she get this awesome job of
being a wife and she said
that she became a better person
she became submissive
right
so
that
sent women crazy okay for for some
reason we're gonna delve into that today
um
so i'm gonna ask the woman first okay
alexa um what did you think of the video
first of all
um
i think there were parts that i agreed
with it and there were parts that i
disagreed with it but before i get into
my own opinion i do find it quite
interesting
that
i mean i guess this is just social media
but i definitely do find it interesting
how
people are so quick to comment on other
people's relationship statuses i mean
this woman is clearly married she's
clearly happily married she's having the
time of her life it is successful
is it really our business to judge
but i'm going to say anyways um me
personally i think yeah there were some
parts i agreed with as part i disagreed
with
as someone who is currently excelling
in their career
um relationships aren't really a
priority of mine
um but i have been in relationships
before
i'm not married evidently i have not
lived with a person before so i guess i
do not have the experience
of women who are in those positions to
fully comment but i think me personally
with the way
i still want to be able to have my sense
of identity and autonomy when it comes
to a relationship i still want to be my
own person i still want to
um
maintain my career
and my success and i love what i do i
love the things that i work on um i
enjoy working and i personally wouldn't
want to be a stay-at-home wife for the
rest of my life that doesn't
sit right with me
however
i definitely do believe in
providing for a person
um
i definitely do believe in cooking and
cleaning i love cooking
and i definitely but i do think it goes
both ways i think
if i'm the person who comes home first
and my partner hasn't come home yet i'll
happily cook i'm happily clean i'll
happily
do what i need to do if my partner comes
home first i would prefer him to cook or
him to clean or whatever i just think
i don't mind putting in the effort i
don't mind submitting if you wish to
call it that to my partner but
i would want the energy to be
reciprocated i think a lot of the times
i hear
men
wanting women to submit to their
partners
um
as a way of control as a way of
okay she submits to me so
i can do whatever i want
i think my way of submitting to a
partner is i submit to you because i
love you and because you love me you
show me the love and affection and you
meet my needs and my desires and if you
do that
then i'm happy
to put in as much effort
and meet your needs and desires
yeah okay interesting ash you saw the
video yeah i did i did see the video
what did you think with that
like like she said that like
people are very
like want to be involved with people's
business and the day she's getting her
back you know like she's in a situation
where
she can she can do that she can do i
feel like people wish
that they were in that situation i feel
like if they were in that situation
they wouldn't be complaining in the
comments you know what i mean
so but with the submission thing it's a
thing where
for like
i feel like it's like the word
submission right now today
that's a bad word you know me like oh
wait when you oh you always be
submissive what you want me to get on my
knees and that like people are not going
to mess with that but there's a posit
can we say there's a there's a positive
like outtake of being submissive like
people people don't see that like that
view of the word bit of being like
submissive
but
i just thought like
my personal opinion on the video
actually is a thing where
she chose she wants to be there so that
she's can't do what she's in if she can
meet her husband's needs and she likes
doing it let that girl do a thing
you understand but it's a thing where
people in the comments are saying
telling her how the way she should live
her life you know what matter is like
my life and you're telling me how the
way i should live it and not be this
when i'm happy doing this i agree but
you're telling me
no over the screen no you shouldn't live
like this you should be you should be
doing stuff for yourself oh she's happy
bro it's like she said in her in a video
she's got a husband that
that looks good
that provides
and she's got to do like of course like
she has to do
like things for him as well to balance
it out i think people when people
well i think today when people think
about housewives i feel like they think
of the view of they don't do anything
how far like she said the housewife
being a housewife is a job you know
you have to you look after the house you
look after the kids and also
your husband as well
but yeah that's my
so why do you think it was that um
so many women
were
upset alexa go on why do you think so
many women were upset i think you know
what it is i think it's quite a
sensitive time for women i think in the
last year especially there's been a lot
of
talks on women's rights and the topic of
feminism especially when it comes to
you've seen hashtags like not all men
and things like that there's been a lot
of concern around women's safety and
women's independence and whatnot i think
especially in when it comes to social
media you will see a lot of women who
want to uphold this front that they
should be independent that they should
have it all together and that they
should and
that that is that is a that's a great
thing but i think i think a lot of
people
how do i say this i think a lot of
people
they are struggling on what they want
their identity to be because
tick tock will show you so many
different sides of how you can be a
woman you will see the side that's okay
independent i make my own money i live
my life i have the time of my life i
yeah my life is great and women see that
we're like yes that's powerful that's
empowering yes i want to live that life
oh she's so motivational she's so
inspiring great lovely i want to
replicate that i want to have my own
money and then
you see the other side of women where
it's like actually no i want to submit i
want to
i want i want to provide for a man i
just want to live a simple soft life as
they're calling it these days um
and that works for them and i think
there's just kind of
there's there's just i think mixed
emotions about what people truly want
and i think it also depends on the state
that you're coming to social media with
i think there's been times when i've
come on social media i've been
heartbroken or i've been angry at man
and so if i'm seeing all these personal
talking about independence i'm thinking
no man bye
i don't want to see you get out of my
business i'm an independent woman by
myself
but there are times when i come on
social media and i'm just like actually
you know what
that simple life does seem nice it does
seem and so i think there is definitely
that
confusion about a lot of what a lot of
what a lot of women want but um i think
rhino is just a sensitive
time for women um
there's just been so much discussion
around feminism and how
um women treat themselves and how they
should be treated by men and yes you
talk about feminism is you saying
do you think feminism is a good thing
for women
yes
um
i i think it is um
but my personal belief so there are
different strands of feminism i study
politics so different ways i'm gonna
we're gonna get to technicalities
yeah they're radical feminists
i'm the radical feminist um saying that
kill all men and all that men should die
like them once that's crazy listen and
it's and it's so hard for someone like
me who i'm a i'm a motivational speaker
i'm a public speaker so i take to my
social media platforms and i like to
advocate for all different types of
issues um but one being women's rights
and
an example i'll give you was last year
and one of my videos went viral i was
talking about the hashtag not all men
and the reason i had an issue with it is
i was talking about it in response to
women's trauma so if a woman is coming
forward to a man let's say i'm talking
to you actually and i'm sitting down
with you and i'm like okay this has just
happened to me
um
and
without actually taking my story into
consideration your response is yeah but
it's not all men i would find that quite
disrespectful because me telling you my
story is not me attacking you
but there was a lot of people who had a
problem with that and then there were
but then there was also the people in my
comments who were making life much more
difficult for me because they're talking
about yeah but there's women who are
going around saying kill all men
and these type of radical feminists like
well you're making my job more difficult
because i don't hate men i want to be
able to
support women and talk about women in a
liberating way that doesn't drag any
other but when you say women
yeah
what rights don't women have in this
modern day